يبدو ان قرار حزب الشعوب الديمقراطي بعدم
الدفع بمرشح في الانتخابات الرئاسيه
التركيه سيمثل مع تبرا انتكاسه طبعا
محتمله لمساعي الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان
للفوز بفتره جديده فبالرغم من ان الحزب
الذي يشكل ثالث اكبر كتله برلمانيه ويحظى
بنسبه تاييد تتجاوز العشره بالمئه على
مستوى تركيا بالرغم من انه لم يعلن رسميا
موقفه بشان من سيدعم في الانتخابات بالرغم
من ذلك الا ان قاده الحزب عقدوا محادثات
الاسبوع الماضي مع كمال كليتش الدار اوبلو
الذي قدم اوراق ترشحه اليوم عن المعارضه
في الانتخابات وبينما يامل
في بناء تحالفات مع الاكراد والمحافظين
ليتمكن من حسم المنافسه لصالحه يعد تحالف
حزب العداله والتنميه الذي يتزعم اردوغان
معارض قوي للحركه الكرديه
ولمطالبها بالحقوق الثقافيه وهذا طبعا ما
يزيد من التوقعات بان يندفع الاكراد اكثر
نحو خيار المعارضه يرى مراقبون ان اردوغان
يواجهوا اصعب تحدي انتخابي منذ صعوده الى
السلطه لاول مره فالانتخابات تاتي في ظل
ازمات متتاليه من بينها ارتفاع معدل
التضخم وعدم الرضا بشان تصدى الحكومه
للزلزال المدمر الذي وقع في فبراير الماضي
واودى بحياه ثمانيه واربعين الف شخص على
الاقل